des face-à-face l'informel pour
favoriser le recrutement des personnes
handicapées
pour la troisième année consécutive
handicafé a pris ses quartiers dans le
centre commercial sqy ouest à montigny
36 groupes et entreprises spécialisées
dans le bâtiment
l'aide à la personne ou encore l'intérim
ont répondu présent je leur demande de
venir c'est long des offres sinon on
leur dit écoutez les os ne correspond
pas à ce que nous avons donc elles ne
viennent pas le principe a été initié
dans l'essonne par l'adapt association
pour l'insertion sociale et
professionnelle des personnes
handicapées
on a eu cinq six candidats aujourd'hui
chez o2 on a signé la charte de la
diversité
on a signé aussi un partenariat enfin
une convention avec l'agefiph
voilà on travaille beaucoup on a un
siège basé au mans on a une charge et de
handicap et qui travaille beaucoup sur
le handicap n'a pas du tout enfin vous
avez prouvé votre bonheur alors j'ai
trouvé une candidature donc du coup
étant donné moi je suis chargé de
mission je vais rentrer à mon bureau et
je vais transférer la candidature donc
aux différents magasins que le candidat
souhaite l'opération s'avère être un
outil des deux entreprises de plus de 20
salariés qui ont depuis 2005
l'obligation d'embaucher 6 % de
personnes handicapées dans le cas
contraire elle reverse une taxe à
l'agefiph
cette association de gestion de fonds
propose des services pour faciliter
l'insertion professionnelle des
personnes handicapées a bien accueilli
pas du tout le stress et entre au
service fut l on sent un peu avec la
passion tout ça en 2011 handicafé a
permis d'effectuer 45 recrutement au
sein de 17 entreprises